you knew this video was coming yeah had
to is we have a new trailer to the new
movie that's one of my most anticipated
movies of the year starting one of the
best actors working today and involving
one of my favorite characters of all
time it starts out and he's on this bus
he's making this kid laugh and his mom's
like can you stop which kind of shows
where the dude's coming from I kind of
take it as like he's like yeah I could
navigate life as a kid and I relate to
kids but adult life is just [ __ ] let's
take it back to a simpler time a simpler
premise but it's when he's that his
therapist
it's the heartbreaking line right it's a
peek behind the curtain you see the man
because the Joker's still a guy came
from somewhere what made him snap the
trigger goes on and of course shows more
of him getting beaten down and lively
Robert De Niro's making fun of him he's
better he's Robert De Niro's character
the host of the show it looks like he
comes out dancing on stage which means
the Joker is now the host of the
greatest show on earth life which I do
wonder he's there among the crowd of
clowns as Arthur Fleck do the clowns
inspire him to be the Joker does the
Joker inspire people to be the clown
does he see a group of maniacs looking
for a leader he's like I'll be that
later Thomas Wayne does his salt the guy
though what's he do what's he say it was
bland punches him you know when he finds
out Bruce Wayne's Batman he's gonna be
like yeah your dad was a dick the creepy
shots this shot right there
that's hands down the creepiest looking
thing that's probably the greatest look
at the Joker's soul ever which is laughs
I saw in the last trailer I was like it
doesn't sound like there's any soul
behind his laugh
like he's just like a guy emulating and
mimicking a laugh even Heath Ledger's
Joker sounded like he was genuinely
amused when he would laugh I like that
take because he's a monster what makes a
monster laughs monstrous things right
this is an emotionless guy emulating a
laugh like there's nothing really there
that's an interesting take it's creeping
the trailer I hope it lands in the movie
and I feel like it will because that's
the soul of the movie this guy who's
like all I have are bad thoughts I mean
he does seem genuinely more amused when
he gets punched in the face I do like
that last line in the trailer though
when you bring me out can you introduce
me as Joker and there it is like there
was one part of me when I saw it in the
trailer I was like I would have liked to
have seen that in the movie point is
Gotham's gonna know who he is now I love
that stuff you know he's getting revenge
on De Niro
he talks a mad [ __ ] one could argue De
Niro pushed him to this point one of the
many causes anyone in the trailer every
once in a while you do hear the song
send in the clowns
it's in there it's within the music
playing during the trailer die be
blatantly is at the end of the trailer
the thing that concerns me about this
movie is really the director Todd
Phillips hasn't given us something that
produced the kind of weight the kind of
gravity this movie looks like it
requires granite maybe just not had the
opportunity but it's just it's my one
concern but if he pulls it off dude and
I love it this is final trailer it's
like you get two trailers old-school
style you know get nine thousand of them
leading up to the movie you get to a
teaser trailer and a final trailer at
worst even if this movie sucks for bid
but if it does I feel like I can with
confidence say I'll probably walk out of
the movie going yeah but walking Phoenix
crushed it hopefully what looks to be
his performance and the movie both line
up to give a great movie it's one of my
most anticipated of the year I hope by
the end of the years one of my favorites
of the year I mean I've heard the online
chatterings that some people are afraid
that this Joker movies gonna incite and
gun violence or something which first of
all video games don't cause gun violence
and neither do movies and if movies do
then video games do you can't cherry
pick which one you want but second of
all I don't want him to bend to that
kind of fear I don't want people to be
like all right well I guess I can't show
my art let me alter things before it
goes to theater I don't want that I mean
this is this is a tunnel through the
Joker's mind this is a deep dive this is
the front row seat to the Joker's pain
if you walk through something like that
going oh that wasn't unsettling at all
that probably wasn't an accurate
representation of it right so the new
trailer - Joker have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more send in
the clowns
[Music]